my guest today visited every single
country in the world by the time he
turned 35 years old the number is 193. i
think the last country he visited was
norway and on top of that you know
businessman author wrote a book called
the 100 startup he wrote many books uh
one of them sold seven hundred thousand
copies uh he wrote a book called the art
of non-conformity new york times
bestseller wall street journal
bestseller with that being said chris
gillabo thank you so much for being a
guest on valuetainment
thanks for having me it's a big honor
[Music]
i've been to 40 or 50 countries and i
feel like i've been all around but 193
what inspired you to want to do that
uh you know it's interesting because i i
was inspired when i had been to about 40
countries
um that's when i started thinking about
it i was like you know i always liked to
travel i was an aid worker for several
years
um before i was an entrepreneur i
actually was kind of starting some of
the entrepreneurship around the same
time and i've always been into like goal
setting and making my list every day and
all that so i made a list of all the
countries you know i had been to and i
was like oh that's a lot of countries
that's pretty good you know i was like
25 or something and so uh i set a goal
to go to 100 countries i was like it'd
be cool to go to 100 countries you know
before i die and then i started working
towards that and realized well that's
kind of easy because
it's basically half the number of
countries and if you're just going to do
half of something
then you can pick and choose you know if
you get stuck somewhere something is
hard to get a visa for then you just
don't go there and so i thought they
make it a real challenge you know and so
the real challenge was to do them all
by my 35th birthday and so i finished
you know when i was 35 in norway as you
mentioned so it was a great experience
man it was great crazy very fortunate to
have been able to do it how was north
korea
north korea was fine north korea was i
went at a time in which um things were a
little bit quieter there i didn't get to
spend as much time as i would like uh so
hopefully i get a chance to go back but
i went to kish island you know i didn't
actually get to go to the mainland of
iran but hopefully at some point very
cool what what was what was the most by
the way the entire time when he did this
uh were you married were you single were
you uh engaged were you
yeah
i was married i was married like uh so
we were aid workers together and then uh
i went back to the states we both went
back to the states i did my grad school
and so i was kind of traveling um you
know maybe a week or two every month and
then back home for the rest of the time
now how are you making the money while
you're doing this i mean i saw some of
this stuff you said the first hundred
countries cost you thirty thousand
dollars i didn't get what the last 93
costs but how are you making money while
you're doing this
yeah okay a couple points there so um
you know first of all when i was 19
that's when i started working for myself
and i i realized pretty early on i
wasn't good at working for other people
um i have this 80d kind of personality
in which like i'll give 110 you know if
i believe in something but if i don't
believe in it it's kind of hard you know
give 20
so that's difficult in your average job
right so i started by selling things on
ebay this goes back 23 years you know
like when all that stuff was new online
auctions e-commerce
i learned how to do some consulting i
learned how to do website design i'm
just learning like all these kind of
random projects but it was you know i
was able to like support myself doing
that for about 10 years and for me i was
very motivated
by freedom you know freedom personal
security
options for myself to be able to like
set my own schedule i wasn't really like
i didn't know much about the startup
world i wasn't trying to like build a
sustainable scalable business it was
very much about freedom you know how can
i do um you know what's more of what's
important to me and then eventually like
all this turned into a career
you know i started writing about the
journey to every country and then
started writing books and you know
interviewing other entrepreneurs and
such but that really was uh was
secondary you know at first it was just
like this is a cool thing this is a
quest i like the challenge there's
nothing public about it um and so then
it turned into that uh more public
facing kind of thing
what was the dollar amount on the last
93 do you remember yeah that's a good
question um so i don't actually know the
dollar amount for the second definitely
would be more than 30 000 i would say
because you know things get more complex
you know as you're kind of like i used
to when i'm starting out like i could
travel around the world you know or go
to like one region and get like five
countries you know that was great but
then you know for those last countries
i'm like flying all the way to like
azerbaijan or you know back or whatever
so it was definitely it was definitely
more but by at that point you know like
i have this career that's kind of
sustaining it and it was also like on
the tail end of it so willing to put
some more in but it wasn't like an
extravagant amount like people imagine
it's like millions of dollars definitely
it's not that you know and the whole
thing about the thirty thousand i was
like
thirty thousand bucks you know to go to
a hundred countries like the value there
is just tremendous you know it's
tremendous the life experiences that i'm
gonna have
compared to like buying a car or
whatever well now cars cost more than
thirty thousand dollars but back then
you know that was like yeah a nice car
you know and i'm like
i don't need a nut car when i can have
the you know the world basically so for
me it was you know 100 worth it what
what place was uh you left and you said
i was not expecting this place to be
this amazing and what place was it you
went in with such high expectations you
came out saying you know i was cool but
nothing crazy
yeah okay okay i like how you ask that
because people are always like what's
your favorite country and i hate that
question you know it's like a dumb
question right
but um the way you set it up is good i'm
actually had a really good visit in
armenia you know like i traveled from
like where was i was going from uravan
to uh
where was i going um i forget it was
like i did like a minibus kind of trip
you know through the country stayed
there for a few days i really enjoyed it
actually i got to learn a little bit
more about armenian culture which i
didn't know a lot about before i went um
so that was good i'd love to go back um
as for what you know the other the other
part of it
i don't know i mean like the south
pacific
um i would say like you know it's
interesting culture i don't know it's
where i want to like be and live i'm
kind of a little bit more of a
fast-paced kind of person and you know
things are a little bit more laid back
there so i respect that
but for me like that wasn't a place that
i want to go spend a whole lot of time
makes sense makes sense so here's a
couple things i'd want to uh uh focus on
today one obviously the the
mindset of uh non-conformity your book
you call it the art of non-conformity
and the other one is uh you know you
talked about 23 years ago
which your 78 baby april fourth were
born the same year you're six months
older than me so 23 years ago i was also
doing some stuff on ebay how old were we
we were 20 years old right so yeah i was
doing i was doing cards baseball cards i
was selling a bunch of weird things but
so so i want to also target on
how today if if you and i were 14 years
old 15 years old how can a 14 15 16 year
old make money today
uh while living with their parents while
they're still going to school all that
stuff we can spend some time on that but
prior let's first start off with the art
of non-conformity so the concept we hear
about the whole thing you know the most
miserable people in the world are those
who make everybody else happy but not
themselves you know but we're so much
about wanting to please everybody how do
you how do you embrace this concept of
non-conformity where you're not trying
to please everybody but some of the
people in your life that maybe matter
the most you do want to make sure you're
making some of them proud how's that
mindset of non-conformity to you yeah
yeah yeah well i definitely want to go
back to the the reselling thing so we
could talk a good bit about that uh but
i mean for me non-conformity
um you know first and foremost it's a
it's a mindset you know the central
message of like everything i've done for
the past two years
not two years ten years you know is uh
you don't have to live your life the way
others expect
okay so you know people in your life
even good people in your life let's say
they have all sorts of expectations you
know for how they want you to live and
the decisions they want you to make and
and um
you know it's not at all like saying you
have to like
not be concerned with their feelings or
you know not be a good friend or family
member or partner but ultimately you're
actually going to be a better friend a
family member or partner
if you are actually being kind of
intentional about your own goals and
what you want to to do with your life
and how to be intentional and
you know
i guess i i used to worry a lot about
what people thought of me and there's
this quote about i think it's like
george bernard shaw about how you'd
worry
you know a lot less about what people
think of you you know once you realize
how seldom they do like most people
actually don't really care that's right
um but we're all trapped in this we're
all trapped in like
you know thinking about our actions our
behavior our decisions as you know
what's somebody going to to think and i
actually think it's very empowering to
be able to say you know i
what is important to me what is
important to me and to ask questions of
yourself because often it's not just
other people that are holding you back
like you're the one that's holding back
very often
um and so i just kind of learned to ask
these why questions why do i i just for
a long time i had this like screen saver
on my laptop and whenever i open the
laptop it says like why are you doing
this basically so i kind of have to look
at that every time like why am i doing
this you know like we get in these
patterns of um
this is my routine i'm just doing this
by rote and i started questioning that
more and more and that helped me to make
better decisions and ended up developing
this into you know a bit more of a
philosophy and a community that people
have kind of latched on to
but ultimately it's about thinking for
yourself you know choosing for yourself
and also trying to make the world a
better place i don't think they're
they're exclusive
yeah i i like the the way you put it and
by the way would you say that's what uh
inspired the world domination or was the
world domination inspired art of
non-conformity
i started the art of non-conformity
first and then i wrote a manifesto
called a brief guide to world domination
that was like just outlining some of my
ideas i liked a very provocative title
you know like people are passing it
around and stuff and then from there
i was like
let's bring everybody together let's do
like i was doing meetups in different
cities when i was traveling it's really
interesting because the people who came
out they all had their own story they're
all like working on stuff and they often
felt uh maybe misunderstood you know by
some people around them
a lot of them did want to start a
business
and they were in kind of traditional
jobs they're trying to figure out how to
navigate that so i was like let's bring
everybody together and i called it the
world domination summit you know so it
kind of grew from there so we've been
doing that for for nine years now
i love that title world domination
summit now the the concern would be is
your last name a german last name
it is not okay i mean that's just one
thing is like you know you start that
you choose something like nine years ago
and you kind of live with it for a long
time like maybe i wouldn't call it that
necessarily now for a variety of reasons
but uh you know that's okay it is what
it is i love it that's i mean i i just
have to tell you i love that i love the
freaking title and uh i don't know the
number but i saw somewhere around 10 000
people have come over the years
and you put some great events together
which is great but let's go back let's
go now back to the uh uh you know if if
you were
14 years old right it's a different
world to day 14 than when you and i were
you know some i don't know what the
number is 14 was what 29 years ago for
us right when we were 14 that sounds
like a long time so when you and i were
i made money i don't i would buy 90s 99
hats and i would sell them for seven
bucks i'd buy cards
and i would flip them i'd buy you know
hats shoes you know a bunch of weird
things that i would sell right but i
wonder what we would do if we were 14
today in high school so i'll turn it to
you how how would you make money today
as a young teenager young entrepreneur
at 14 years old
so i think this is really interesting
because
you know no doubt so much has changed as
you said in all those years i can't
believe it's been you know 29 years as
you said so much has changed you know
like the iphone wasn't out there now we
have all these different platforms you
know we're much more connected than we
were etc etc new business models however
you know the way that you guys started
in business the way that i got started
it's actually still quite relevant like
reselling is still very accessible most
of it hasn't changed that much you know
like most of it in terms of like you're
trying to find the 99 cent hat you know
maybe it costs like five bucks now
you're trying to sell that for 30 bucks
or whatever and
i mean people can do that there's all
kinds and like there's so many platforms
now with like facebook marketplace and
offer up and uh gumtree and all kinds of
others um without a lot of capital at
all i mean 50 bucks even even if you
don't have any money you can start with
the stuff that you already have like
sell your own stuff and then use that 50
bucks to buy other stuff
you know i mean it's it's a process and
that may not be in you know what you end
up doing for your whole life you know
like you're going to go on to other
stuff
but by doing that you're going to learn
about marketing you're going to learn
about how to accept payments you're
going to learn about customer service
you're going to learn about copywriting
all this kind of all these kind of
skills that will that will help so i
think that's always a great first start
i mean the second thing would be
okay so once you have a little bit of
experience
you know now you know it doesn't really
matter if you're 14
anyone can have you know a website
that's actually like doing some kind of
e-commerce thing anybody can offer a
service you know online nobody cares if
you're 14. like it's not really relevant
it's it's like what is the product what
is the service you know so there i feel
like you know we could look at all sorts
of different things but it depends on
what your goal is if you're trying to
just make some money and get into it
really quickly make more money than you
would you know working
you know at a restaurant or something
then you can do that today i think
what were you how were you making money
at 14 were you the guy that was always
making money were you the young hustler
or were you the guy with the good grades
well if i wasn't the guy the good grades
i dropped out of high school and i went
to one year of high school i dropped out
um
i wasn't really selling stuff at 14 or
15. it was more like 18 or 19 that's
when i started
um so i mean i did work at a restaurant
when i was 14 washing dishes and then my
last job job was at fedex
in memphis tennessee when i was 19 like
putting boxes on a truck and it's like
my college job and then when i learned
about ebay and those kind i was like
all of a sudden i'm making 15 to 20 an
hour you know and back then you know for
everybody who's much younger than us
like back then i was making eight
dollars an hour at fedex and i was like
well okay you know this is better and
also i had no idea what i was doing with
ebay like if i learn if i study i can do
much better and
and not just the money i think this is
the key point like i was so attracted to
the idea of building something and the
idea of having freedom and nobody's
gonna tell me
you know what to do today and when to go
to work and the ironic thing is i
actually worked a lot more you know like
when i could choose how much so you know
you probably get that too like it's like
when nobody's telling you to go to work
i'm like i'm actually there early i'm
staying late because i'm excited about
it so weird yeah um you know
the dynamic is it's a best best way to
describe it is you know sometimes at
least for me
is uh uh when you're babysitting versus
it's your own baby you know you're
you're taking care of somebody else's
baby you're like hey let's it's all good
i like i'll do my job but if it's my own
baby man i'll go on two hours of sleep
uh right now we got a we got a 12 week
16 week daughter we got four kids
we got a nine seven five thank you and a
14 week old so
sleep is a very valuable asset right now
the family
yeah so so you're doing some of those
two hour uh oh there's no question about
last night was a special night because
she slept from 11 05 and that hasn't
happened for like uh uh i don't think
it's happened period so it was a special
night for us last night but but going
back to uh
you know the the teenage uh
uh uh how to make money today as a
teenager you were saying you had a job
when you were making your money you
didn't really start doing the reselling
stuff till 1819 uh when you were doing
the reselling what were the products
that you were reselling on ebay
yeah i mean i didn't really specialize
it was
it was like i looked for what was
selling i looked and then i looked at to
see like where could i get you know
those items so it was like coffee it was
lego sets it was video games
um some clothes some clothing items i
think i did some sneakers those are hard
because of sizes you know yeah i stock a
whole bunch of inventory but
um and that coffee i got into just
randomly because
like i saw like oh there's other auction
sellers selling this really expensive
coffee you know like where does it come
from oh it comes from jamaica where are
they buying it from like there's got to
be a way to like reverse engineer this
process
which these days is actually easier than
it was you know back then but even then
it wasn't that hard to like figure out
you could place an order you could order
from somebody and then see what shows up
and then like okay i'm going to call
that manufacturer or that wholesaler
and
you know you can also see what's selling
and see like oh whether is this selling
consistently is it selling at a price
that i can profit from
so i did everything from you know those
items i mentioned i did cigars for a
while
cigars wow you know
headphones you know i mean anything you
know i wasn't trying to like have a
specialty for me it was like what's
selling how can i acquire the inventory
and again it's just me it's not like i'm
building some warehouse or something but
i was thrilled i was absolutely thrilled
you know because here i am like 19 20
and you know not making a huge amount of
money but i was making more money than i
ever was you know certainly doing
anything else um so i thought it was
really cool
the concept of hundred dollars a startup
you know revenge the way you make a
living do what you love and create a new
future it's not a new book it's a
nine-year book but it's done very well
and uh i remember when the book came out
i mean it's a
it was a talk of town everybody was
talking about this book when it first
came out not saying they're not it's got
4 300 reviews so it's a book that's done
very very well but what is the premise
behind a hundred dollar startup to the
audience that doesn't know
the premise is um
you know there's a whole model of
entrepreneurship that you're probably
familiar with from watching shark tank
or silicon valley or anything like that
that's great there's also a whole other
model of entrepreneurship that is based
on
no debt you know bootstrapping yourself
not looking for investors uh focused on
a passion that you have a skill that you
have
and trying to
you know build a business for yourself
right so that business may or may not
scale it may or may not become a 100
million dollar company
but you can certainly build it to a
six-figure business sometimes multiple
six figures sometimes seven figure
so you can do more of what's important
to you and that model at the time was
was really not being
talked about much and i think that's
probably why the book did well like i
went on this tour for my first book art
of non-conformity i went to all 50
states i went to every province in
canada i was talking with my readers
like i'm hearing all these stories about
people that nobody knew about you know
and they weren't famous you know this is
like before social media was really big
and they were making a good living doing
something that
you know like they never thought of
themselves as entrepreneurs i was
actually very careful about the word
entrepreneur i didn't use it very much
in that book because a lot of people
find it you know hard to relate to you
know they think entrepreneur is what
i've seen on those tv shows or whatever
and so that whole model is like you know
you can do something right now with the
skills you have what you need to learn
is how to adapt those skills into the
new economy because you already have a
lot you know what you need to do is
translate you know or transfer those
skills yeah
so would you consider yourself today an
entrepreneur or solopreneur
yeah that's a good question i don't um
i don't really make too much of a
distinction i'm probably much more of a
solopreneur still i mean i have a team
but it's a it's a small team i i'm not a
great manager like i don't want to have
a lot of employees so i purposely
you know keep things pretty small or
pretty lean at least um but i'm also
starting different projects and such so
i don't i guess i'm i've got
entrepreneur i suppose
yeah like
your data and you and my dad you guys
are born seven days uh he's an april
10th baby okay
and and my dad let me tell you
i i've not met an april person i didn't
get along with but uh april guys from my
experience lots of trust lots of
independence uh lots of i'm gonna figure
this out lots of you can't tell them you
can't do something because that's like
the kiss of death god forbid you tell an
april baby you can't do something
they're gonna spend their entire life
trying to prove to you that they can do
something to the wiring is a different
wiring do you think
do you think like you know in um when i
interview certain people and i'm trying
to
get somebody in a position this has been
my experience
a person who plays better in a solo game
for example a tennis player
you know a
kid like my one of my sons just loves
swimming or tennis something that's just
he controls
the success right it's his he controls
the success the other one is like it's
like
i want to be on a team i want to do this
i want to do that
you know do you think this is more like
a dna of wiring the way you are where
look i'm i'm wired this way i want to be
a solopreneur i don't like to manage
people because i don't like to be
managed i kind of know what's good for
me leave me alone i don't need to be
worth a few billion dollars i kind of
want to go do my own thing you know a
book like yours 100 startup or four hour
work week do you think there's like a
wiring where it's part of dna versus the
other guy's like i want to go build
something with thousands of people
yeah yeah i i don't know if it's dna or
you know socialization or early
experiences you know that lead to that
or some combination most likely but i do
think that they you know people tend to
fall in one camp or another you know
and it's like uh you know introvert or
extrovert like there's a spectrum of
these things it's not like you're like
all the way one all the way the other so
i mean i also like to work with people
like for the event world domination
summit you know we have a team that
works on that it's very collaborative i
enjoy that
so i think you know no matter which one
you are like you can learn some of the
skills of the other side but i do think
most people are kind of one way or the
other and i think what you know if you
figure that out that's going to help you
you know and uh you know to play to your
strengths and figure okay what is the
way that i'm going to change the world
you know that's somewhat somewhat unique
because if i'm just trying to develop
all my skills to the same level then you
know nobody's going to care about that
i'm not really going to have an impact
that's right you're like everybody else
if you do that so the the last book that
you have um
uh uh uh which is about finding your
passion i forgot the title of it not
side hustle what's the last book not
money tree is called the money tree it's
like finding the fortune in your own
backyard so that's um sorry maybe you
had another question about that not not
money tree the one with the red the uh
uh red um
born for this born for this yeah about
uh finding the work you were meant to do
yeah so so help me help me with the
system of that okay so i'm i'm ambitious
i'm 18 years old i'm 25 years old i'm
like dude listen chris i'm telling you i
feel like there's some firing me i want
to do something but do i go be like this
guy that guy this guy what do i do it's
so busy right now it's so noisy right
now how do i figure myself out what's
that formula yep
i think the first thing you do if you're
that you know 1925 let's say young 20s
you know guy or woman i think you um
you know you take some of the pressure
off like just keep them ambition
ambition 100 the fire the fuel
but i think we put too much pressure on
people to figure out their life purpose
you know when they are 22 23 and i think
the way that you actually get to that is
by doing a bunch of stuff you know i
mean if you know 100
like there are people who know like this
is the thing i want to do in life and
that's great go and do that but i think
those are the minority like very small
minorities i think most of us we figure
out what our thing is by doing a bunch
of different stuff you know and by being
willing to experiment by willing willing
to start different projects and and also
to leave them behind right to be willing
to like abandon something um so i wrote
a lot in that book born for this about
the power of giving up and the power of
quitting because i think um
something especially in western society
like this belief about never quitting
and like persistence is the highest you
know
the highest value i think that's wrong
right and most successful people have
actually quit all kinds of things you
know they have tried something and then
they have walked away from it they have
not been they have not
not been like unwilling to say okay you
know that was a mistake or maybe it
wasn't a mistake it was just like that
was what i was doing for now and now i'm
going to do something different so i
think the first thing you do is you just
you try different stuff and then you
know from there there's like there's
some various assessments in the book and
it's like a model of uh joy money and
flow which i think are the three
components you know of kind of what
makes us you know happy what we find
meaningful so you want to find something
that you actually enjoy doing and look
forward to doing and like that's not
everything but that is an important part
of it money again not everything but
pretty important like it needs to be
sustainable it needs to you know have
value in in this modern world and flow
is that um that aspect of work in which
you're like man i'm really good at this
thing and like the hours just passed by
and i don't even notice how much time
went by and maybe um i this is actually
really easy for me other people find it
difficult but for me this is easy you
know figuring out whatever that thing is
and then trying to find the combination
they're in you know where it's like i
really enjoy this thing it actually
makes some money and i'm good at it like
we're always searching for it too right
by the way it's not like you get to it
one day you're like there i am you know
i think it's always a lifelong journey
but if you use those three points as
like these are my anchors and if i'm
getting too far away from any one of
them
then you know maybe that's okay for a
time like if you're really in debt and
you're like
man i have to do whatever i can to make
some money then that's fine you know you
focus on that even if you don't love it
for a time but in the long term you're
going to be the most successful if
you're trying to do all three of them i
like that joy money flow
enjoy money flow
and knowing the fact that the most
successful people you know have probably
could quit a lot of different things
before they finally found something i
quote i read 20 years ago it said
sometimes on a way to a dream you get
lost and find a bigger one
sometimes on the way to you're like oh i
want this i want this i want this i'm
like no i really want this that's what i
wanted
it's amazing how that works out because
initially i thought it was all about
money
because we grew up without money then
that money gets squared away then you're
like what am i doing next and let's do
something bigger than that so the money
the money tree a story about finding the
fortune in your own backyard how do we
found
find the fortune in our backyard some
people's backyard is a small backyard so
how do we how do we find that money in
our backyard
right right right i mean you know it's
meant to be kind of a metaphor of like
you know
something that you know the skill that i
have or you know the passion that i have
or maybe it's a hobby and i think
nobody would nobody would pay money for
this thing you know but you know i had a
story on the podcast of uh of a young
guy like doing fortnite coaching
basically and making a lot of money you
know making like 7 000 a month you know
coaching people in fortnight you know
and uh so
in your own backyard it's like you make
a list of your skills of your passions
and you try to figure out what's the
alignment between these things and you
know what people are paying for what's
the convergence point so i kind of go
into that but that book is is basically
the
um the story version of hundred dollar
startup so 100 startup is is very
instructional it's a nonfiction book uh
moneytree actually wanted to kind of
you know write something that's a little
bit different for people who might not
read business books so
i kind of created a whole like world for
that well you just gave me an idea here
so
since you
have written these books you're going to
be interviewed on these things so you're
going to be on a lot of different
podcasts and you wrote a book also on
side hustle from idea to income in 27
days
maybe spit out some of the most unique
strangest side hustles you've seen
people do like the seven thousand
dollars a month you know fortnight uh
consulting business the kids running
what are some of the most unique random
strange side hustles you've seen unique
random i mean so i've been doing this
podcast uh every single day since uh
january 1 2017. it's a daily podcast
comes out seven days a week so we're on
episode 1700 something you know and i'm
telling all these different different
stories so um
yeah like let's see like i had somebody
who is doing dating app coaching like
for your dating profile
for men right so this is a woman who's
helping men have a better you know
dating profile she was making a lot of
money with that okay there was um
there's this couple that uh was really
into dachshunds like the dog you know
but specifically dachshunds like not all
dogs just toxins so they created this
website uh that's like e-commerce for
docs and lovers if it if it's not a
million-dollar you know a year business
right now it is high six figures like
and it's all
you know right but specificity is the
thing specificity um
there's so much to that i mean so i've
had manufacturing stuff i've had like
lots of service stuff give me i actually
i actually i want to be able to get our
audience let's try to get out of your
brain see if we can extract 10 of them
so far i have three we got to get seven
more okay so one okay we have dating app
coaching which by the way i think so
many people would actually want to help
with that right because it i guess it
would be the sales pitch will be what
i'm gonna help you increase the chance
of getting the girl that you want by
making adjustments on your profile
fantastic so the couple dachshund dogs
that's gonna make a very niche which
what you talked about number three is
the uh the fortnight when you talk about
the kids seven thousand dollars a month
consulting how to play that game what
else keep going tell us yeah yeah let's
see let's see um there's a woman who um
she's in florida actually she created
this uh product called a rinsaroo which
is like a shower
like a shower handle attachment to like
you know rinse off your shoes if you're
on the beach or rinse off with dogs just
going to the beach with her big family
and like there was just one shower in
the house so she created this this is
also multiple six figure now very low
startup costs
um
let's see what else do we got
i did this guy this guy was um
uh was doing drop ship so drop shipping
you know for anybody doesn't know it's
like you're you're buying something and
the company is sending that out you know
to other people so you don't actually
have to touch the inventory so he was
selling live crickets
to reptile owners
so he's like actually selling insects
but he doesn't have to touch that right
he's not doing the inventory you know
and so he's making like a few thousand
dollars a month it's not like a million
dollar business yeah still
right um let's see what else we got um i
did a guy who wrote a blog about fish
tanks so not fish just fish tanks again
the specificity like going to buy an
aquarium you want to buy a fish tank so
he monetizes this using affiliate
marketing right so people are googling
all the time you know which aquarium
should i buy and they're googling the
names of specific models this is a very
uncompetitive
niche right like it's not like
everybody's like i'm going to get into
the fish tank market so he's able to
like rank really high in seo people come
and read his articles they click the
links and no so he actually set this up
this is a guy from the uk
he set it up as a random project like
one weekend you know what's his name do
you know the company's name is is it
something where we can give them
something i can find it real quick um
but um it was actually one of the second
stories i ever had on the on the podcast
um
so i'll get it for you but um he set
this up in a very short period of time
we just google blogging for fish tanks
you're probably gonna find that story um
and
you know set it up in a short period of
time never did anything else with it and
like years and years goes by and he's
still making like three to five hundred
dollars a month from it so three to five
hundred dollars a month for something
you don't do anything for right yeah no
question about it yep
what else so we got four more to go
we're gonna we're gonna put that brain
of yours to work and we're gonna come up
with a four more give me four more
it's a good challenge um i did i did a
sneaker reseller story recently so maybe
he's like following in your footsteps
literally
um with that that dude was doing really
well um he had figured out they have all
these apps now when like a new model
drops and so he had written some
algorithm and then built up this
customer relationship base
um
i had like a librarian who was a dj and
she kind of created this like library dj
kind of model that she's doing in
different cities so she's like traveling
for it
uh what's what's her name so is she
dressed like a librarian like
i don't know everybody's name
no no no no not name no but what is her
niche what is it like by the way i found
the one story british man earned 700 a
month writing fish tank reviews we'll
put the link below if people want to see
that but the librarian dj what's her
niche does she dress like a librarian
does she have a she actually is a
librarian you know she has a librarian
she's a little bit older um so she's not
like what you would expect to be i think
that's part of it it's like this you
know kind of surprise but there's a
whole like like literacy tie into it
andrea graham
andrea graham is that her name andrea
graham librarian most recently i've done
a lot of stories i did a textbook
reseller this is actually something
that's just something people can do
right now like a guy at college you know
is like buying all these textbooks and
like finding a way to like create
this model where he's matching students
with textbooks and that basically pays
his way through grad school so what does
he do say unpack that again textbook he
yep
he's basically bought it's a very simple
model he's buying and reselling
textbooks you know and he does it both
locally and online okay uh speaking of
paying your way through college there
was a woman who
uh she she bred rabbits so she was like
a rabbit breeder and actually made
enough money from that to pay for for
college
um also very low startup cost there
you know so all these kind of things
like it's not like everybody should go
it's not like i'm saying you know you
need to go out and like
drop ship live crickets you need to
become a librarian dj it's really
important to say like there's something
you can do like whatever your thing is
no matter how yeah
you think like nobody else is interested
in this thing but you have something
that you're interested in you know and
and there and there is there here's
here's i think i'm probably at nine or
ten now um there's a woman uh who
did some videos like an online course
about baking bread not just bread but
sourdough bread again the niche
sourdough bread
her name is theresa i forget her last
name
um but she made these videos for
udemy i think and they totally blew up
and she got like a hundred thousand
dollars to make these videos about
sourdough bread and then she made the
sequel and then another video like all
the courses are about sourdough bread
so the first one was filmed with her
iphone and her kitchen and bad lighting
and no audio quality all that kind of
stuff because
you know it doesn't matter it's like the
knowledge it's the knowledge and then
she gets better and improves things
along the way so if she can make all
this money with sourdough bread i know
there's something for everybody yeah
theresa greenway what a great story you
know that's right brett baker so just so
you know you're an overachiever because
we came up with 11. okay
man i felt the pressure
so let me let me research what's funny
about is like so i've been you know i
wrote a book called 100 side hustles
that has 100 of these stories and i've
done 1700 episodes but whenever people
are like tell me one story i'm like i
can't think of too much pressure to come
up right now but we did it we did it so
we got so let's go through some of them
so one of them is a dating gap coaching
fantastic you got the docs and dogs uh
couple specific you got the fortnite
coaching you got the shower handle which
for the beach you're going out there you
got the drop shipping life crickets to
reptiles you got the blog fish tang
fish tank blogs you got the sneaker uh a
reseller great librarian dj textbook
reseller rabbit breeder which you know
very interesting to i'd love to give
that business card to somebody what do
you do for a living i read rabbits right
very interesting and then you got the
online baking sourdough bread theresa
greenway so the reason why i wanted to
do this exercise because
you know i think sometimes uh
i'm consulting a pizza company today
okay
it was a pizza company and it was a uh
uh a health uh
old folks homes companies what they do
so you got two different businesses
they're both on this call together for
about 90 minutes
and they're having a hard time we read
the book contagious together which is to
come up with the next way to trigger a
story all this stuff i said i said you
know
i got to tell you
my wife and i we put our kids through a
swim course in l.a simply because one
video went viral and this school this
school that we put the kids through is
called isr i'm trying to get the name
for you just to share it with you
it's called isr anyways infant swim
rescue and i don't i don't know if you
remember when this video went viral it
got a few hundred million views on
facebook
they drop the kid in the pool and the
kid flips on its own right i don't know
if you've seen this video or not so
they grew
a few thousand percent in a year they
couldn't even certify people quickly
enough because of how swamped they were
because parents looked at it and they
said i got to put my kids through it
that's cool every single one of our kids
have gone through that right so the idea
is like with pizza
when you think about pizza you think
about happiness everything you ever did
in your life that you were happy with
you know football you eat pizza movie
with friends pizza hanging out with your
peers pizza so pizza is such a product
link to happiness that you got to remind
the audience what we feel like when
we're having pizza to get those two
together but what you're doing is the
audience now sister says
you know maybe i'm not a good dating app
coach
but maybe instead of crickets maybe i
can sell something else you know there's
so many ways to make money today in
america do you think it's easier to make
money today as a 14 year old than when
you and i were 14.
i think something around the time when
you and i were
that's when it changed i think maybe 10
years before that it was definitely
harder like so now it might be easier
you know than a couple decades ago but i
think we are definitely in the time in
which so many platforms so many networks
everybody's familiar with buying stuff
online i think you know when we were
starting like there was still a lot of
resistance to that like you know is it
going to be safe to use my credit card
on you know online um you know before my
grandma passed away she had a paypal
account and that's why i knew that's
what i knew like okay we're in the new
you know
the new world um i think it's never been
easier let's say that you know it's
never been easier and what you're
pointing out like it's a great story
about the swim class i mean that's like
pointing to this like you know desperate
desperate need you know for safety right
and
um i think all of these models all these
stories you know the reason why i'm like
presenting all these stories all the
time on the podcast and the books it's
to try to like remove excuses you know
it's to try to like remove obstacles and
say well look at this person they
weren't an entrepreneur quote unquote
they didn't go to harvard business
school they didn't they didn't have all
these advantages you know the sourdough
bread woman she was actually like
pretty poor at the time and like living
on benefits and like like a difficult
situation and all that so
if you don't relate to me if you don't
relate to you know one person here maybe
there's somebody there that you can
relate to and all the all the different
you know stories we went through like
they're different models you know so
like e-commerce like the shower handle
that's just a practical like a practical
need great makes sense if you got a
beach house you want
one of those um
some of the other things are like
community the dachshunds you know like
if you have a dachshund you love your
dog you love that breed you want to buy
the dachshund t-shirt and the ducks and
everything
um so tribal identity
so safety tribal identity solving a
problem the dating coach app it's also
pretty pretty uh
serious you know desperate problem like
we want to be loved we want to be we
want to feel uh people are attracted to
us we want to have more people liking or
swiping on the app
um so i think as long as you're focused
on needs like focusing on needs what
people want that's where you kind of
find you know your next thing
you you just spit out a bunch of
different things were those points in
your book or did you just think of them
right now like tribal identity uh you
know if if i'm in the dachshund
community i i can i relate to that i own
shih tzu's if you want shitsu's and
we're about to get an american pitbull
terrier i'm probably going to be part of
that so that's tribal identity but you
said save tell me about the safe part
what was the safe part you explained
well a safety i mean that's like our
it's like our most uh with our baseline
need you know if we don't feel safe then
you know nothing nothing comes after
that so
i mean fire extinguishers insurance you
know smoke detectors like all these
things are sold basically to appeal to
that primary primary need
and then you said loved which makes
sense but you said one other one which
was we want to be attracted we want to
be liked is that kind of the same thing
as loved where we want a lot of likes
i mean we want to feel
we want people we want to be liked you
know we want to be like we also want
what other people want there's something
else to that too you know if other
people like a lot of things that's what
we want to i mean and also just the
solving a problem like i think it's
don't overlook the whole thing about
just solving a simple problem the
textbook reseller also he's solving a
problem you know it's not a sexy
business but you know it paid his way
through school so that's pretty cool
that makes sense listen this was
fantastic i wasn't expecting to get this
much knowledge from you man i thought
this was going to be
you know what this was great we learned
and uh you know the other day we're
sitting here having a conversation we're
trying to do a tick tock dance video
right so
my guy rob who knows how to dance he's
doing dance and i'm you know learning
all these things from them but in that
moment i sat there i told caroline i
said you know what if a person who knows
how to do these tick tock dance videos
even a 15 year old kid there's adults
that'll pay you 500 to go teach them how
to make a video just to you know show to
their audience that they got a few dance
moves there's so many ways to make money
today but anyways absolutely uh chris
uh gillabo thank you so much for making
the time for being a guest on
valuetainment i really enjoyed it we're
gonna put the links to all your books
below so if the audience wants to get
any one of them we'll have the books
below in the description
thank you so much matt i appreciate it
great conversation this was fantastic
take care bye-bye
pretty interesting right we figured 10
we got one more bonus which one of them
you thought was the most creative
comment below if you liked the interview
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel two other videos if you like
this one one is a video i did 14 ways
teenage entrepreneurs can make money i
think that was like five years ago if
you've not seen it click over here and
the other one is common mistakes teenage
entrepreneurs make if you've not seen
that click over here take care everybody
bye
[Music]